sorry welcome to this video playing
great Wow 77 and is coming up with the
Kings gambit huh ok I have more than one
line that I did I play hmm Jerry but I
don't know really and he learned
particularly well this is one of my my
pet lines against it I mean it doesn't
really happen often let you play them
Kings gambit with black yep this is now
are transposing to some normal light out
of them the modern defense that's an
early check still be should be six or
not we should be seven also makes some
sense hmm not sure about this
it's really early a check ok I'm going
we should be sad but I'm kind of unsure
so okay now if I'm canceled he can check
on d5 so maybe we should be six can
undercut so maybe I didn't really go for
the most precise move water now it
should be kind of okay this position
it's not exactly the reputation of the
Kings gambit but I don't think you can
refute it entirely so it's going for see
for now
night III maybe hmm may not see 493 this
is what I'm thinking about
okay i'm going to attack the center here
a little bit c4 yeah I'm not quite sure
actually even night before I just make
some sense night before and maybe it's
got a three okay then I don't really
have a great square so let's do this
this was my original intention you can
take and play d5 maybe but five now yeah
but I was thinking that this cannot be
bad sorry bad for black with the with
the bishop pair and rupee eight coming
and so on he also has said somewhat
weird piece on b3
nice playing this drew yes typical quick
speed I was just thinking that b5 could
be annoying yeah i saw the move but I
thought I I'm just grabbing me too so
okay I'm going to do that not think
about this form for too long didn't
really see what what the big idea is
here maybe d 60 that pawn is the pawn
maybe just t6 trying to be be annoying
about it that's not bad not a bad
continuation he does have rugby one
wow isn't this quite nice for me now
please come with cam them sorry for my
loop gibberish with me coming to d6
should a father and surprising move and
now I'm going back right 96 comes with
the temple yeah so 96 Queen III probably
now I just go back of course and if he
takes b7 I've got 96 and I'm ready for
be 696 okay whoo that's am not very
difficult but took me a while to see
that okay um possible there any way I do
this let's not talk too much [ __ ] I play
this move anyway yeah okay this is he's
going into to I'm swindling mode there
with some desperate attack on the king
certainly what he has to do normal
measure spoons I won't turn to be enough
so H was hanging and i think i will take
it if him allows me to do that
yeah it's not easy for me to do
something about it you should be three
okay i'm grabbing this him and it's
actually a typical move just kind of
gambling that i'm not taking a c2 but i
don't really see why I shouldn't do that
I don't see it it's there's some double
attack or so I don't see it check
so let's see how can i activate stuff
this property of the rook on the fourth
rank is not bad one big problem is that
his Knight has nowhere to go really as
rook age 4 will be killing cannot move
the night maybe 2 h 2 F word Bishop g7
no still don't see you moving anything
here bishop is pretty strong ok now I
have this No then you can take a six
actually so it's not time morning be too
relaxed about it
okay I can do this someone that's mm-hmm
that is okay
maybe next group edge voice and grabbing
the HP if I get the H pawn I should be
okay well okay then I have to do this p
two check check 35 seconds should be
check should be enough really
I'm completely okay with with trading
queens jagiya as you can hardly move
anything in 30 seconds that sense should
be enough to win this just go ahead
cheap on organ can get the second point
into into motion okay just know that no
stalemate please checkmate you know okay
but probably I mean he really helped me
a lot by granting me a bunch of Tempe
I'm not quite sure about that Queenie to
move it's that really what it's done
here I think they normally castle but
I'm not not one hundred percent sure
yeah I can Bishop e7 I cannot be bad
really castles this d for castles yeah
that it's very normal moves no you won't
be should be three
okay I've helped that is kind of okay 93
and takes takes d5 bishop here yeah and
I felt that this should be kind of kind
of equal maybe he has got the passer
down than the D foul and I mean he
shouldn't be in bad shape or anything
should be okay I mean I was happy with
my position but not that I'm much better
or anything okay one that was all that
all felt totally totally normal now we
went here yeah I don't really know i
mean i can take me to write are the
engine actually wants to grab the phone
immediately it has gathered that makes
some sense didn't really think about
that too much probably it's really
better i was kind of I don't know I
didn't really want to deal with this
kind of thing but it really feels like a
pre awkward self pin once you look at
this with a fresh eye now ok taking
their g6 yeah yeah and only here I think
it gets real problematic if he goes
rupee one I mean it's this like enough
activity I mean to compensate for whites
porn loss if I move back here I was
thinking maybe this one but I wasn't
really sure about all this because it is
it kind of it's a bit of a shaky
position here the night is undefended
bishop is depended on the queen but
probably I'm okay because everything is
happening on the dark squares maybe
engine wants to do this and blames
equality trend this move
money but this this cannot be right I
don't don't believe in this one very
much the engine wants to go to g7 though
why is this bad is bad bad come back no
well now the engine is adjusting and
says that this is indeed good fool again
it's kind of wondering why isn't as good
I mean ever get to the six it must be
must be good unless there's some some
tactic that I'm overlooking but the
engine Issus is giving giving nothing in
particular yeah back here cannot take
and now I get to this important square H
fry now be five after that I think I'm
winning therefore this is the engines
move but it's really bad i am making
sure that if i go b5 that I'm really
trading trading us stuff there the way
it went their way to was basically lost
step I cannot really keep it in with any
decent move yeah I grabbed she took yeah
I can really just take it it's a little
bit of a bluff here very often in blitz
chest you tend to just automatically
recapture but I think I can really take
area and it's set minus 5 this is no
nothing special going on Oh Bishop g5
was even better pension check it was it
was winning over the winning all right
okay well thanks for watching